nous sommes engagés dans une guerre ce n'était pas pour
le moment des hommes d'armes cela
implique des informations quelque chose d'important
est arrivé nous avons un espion soviétique nous
voulons que vous le défendiez je suis un
avocat d'assurance j'ai un criminel mort  travail depuis des
années avez-vous représenté de nombreux
espions accusés ce sera une première pour
nous deux vous devriez faire attention les gens ont
peur de cet homme est une menace pour
nous tous savez-vous comment les gens vont nous regarder
la famille d'un homme  essayer de libérer
le traître tout le monde mérite une défense
chaque personne compte à ce moment
vous ne vous référerez pas à l'u2 comme un
avion de reconnaissance
vous allez prendre des photos sur
le territoire soviétique
dites moi ce qui s'est passé ils ont eu notre
pilote espion ou la tête pleine  d'
informations classifiées, ils ont leur gars, nous
voulons que vous négociiez l'échange afin que ce
ne soit pas le gouvernement qui traque vous pourriez
sans un échange thermonucléaire complet
avec l'Union soviétique Je vous parle de
la sécurité de votre pays où
faire  ils veulent que cette négociation ait
lieu il est à Berlin tu me dis juste que
tu ne vas pas courir de danger donne
moi quelque chose à quoi m'accrocher pour que tu fasses
ça pour nous il ne reste que quelques voies avant
les vagues l'état de droit est moins
fermement établi là-bas, évitez simplement l'
interaction avec les gens en général, vous
n'appartenez pas, nous devons avoir la
conversation, nos gouvernements ne peuvent pas
vous êtes un Américain, vous pourriez bien être
détenu, restez définitivement à l'écart du
mur, traversez-le et vous serez abattu  beaucoup
de gens ne veulent pas que cet échange
ait lieu nous ne le laissons pas
ici merci de commencer à s'effondrer
il y a un coût à ces choses le coût
à la fois pour le pays et la famille
ah
nous avons besoin que ce soit un échange
[  Musique]
vous